Tonight--
[laughs]
Hi, my name is
Anais Fairweather,
and tonight I'm gonna tell
you the story,
the true story behind
"A League of Their Own."
- Cheers.
- We start our story with
Marge and Helen Callaghan,
two sisters growing up in
Vancouver, Canada.
These two women
are natural athletes.
They're so [bleep]
sick and tight,
and they're like,
yeah, we joined a fast-pitch
softball league together.
Okay, so now we're gonna fast
forward a little bit to 1942.
We're in the midst
of World War 2,
and the draft is going
on full force.
Now this [bleep]ing guy,
the commissioner of the MLB,
Kenesaw Mountain Landis.
[groans]
I hate saying that name.
- [laughs]
- He's like,
I'm the numero uno
commissioner
of major league
and minor league baseball,
and while I'm calling
the shots,
everyone's being [bleep]ing
drafted into World War 2.
So he's like, okay,
I'll put my big boy pants on.
I'ma figure this out.
He calls Philip K. Wrigley.
Philip K. Wrigley is, like,
chomp, chomp, hello?
And Kenesaw Mountain Landis
is like,
oh, my man,
3,000 minor league players,
major league players
are gone to war.
So Philip K. Wrigley's like,
okay,
I've got an idea for you.
We are gonna capitalize
on the popularity
of women softball.
Badass women.
And it's, like,
the '40s, right?
That's--that's a crazy time
to do this.
So Philip K. Wrigley
and his buddy, Ken Sells,
go out scouting
all throughout the Midwest.
And lo and behold,
who did they run into
but Helen and Marge Callaghan.
- What are they doing there?
- They are playing
fast-pitch softball,
and Helen and Marge are like,
uh, we are dominating
this field.
Philip and Ken run out
to this.
They run out to the field
and they're like,
you, the both of you,
we need you both.
You got to be
on our [bleep]ing team.
And they sign on the
dotted line at $75 a week.
So they're both on
the Minneapolis Marionettes.
[both laugh]
No, Millerettes.
So Marge and Helen are like,
we're on this team,
this is [bleep]ing tight.
They're playing
doubleheaders,
in, like, 115 degree weather,
and Philip K. Wrigley's like,
I know how to sell a product,
and I need these women
to look like women.
These chaperons are like,
I am going to make sure
that their hair is curled,
their lipstick is on,
their makeup is fully done,
their skirts are ironed
before they head out
onto the field.
People are full to watch
these women
in these adorable dresses
play [bleep]ing baseball
like men.
And Marge Callaghan,
Helen Callaghan,
are [bleep]ing knocking
this shit outta the park.
Women are stealing bases.
They're like,
what's up, mother[bleep]?
[laughs]
I don't know why that's funny,
but it's funny.
[both laughing]
Now, Philip K. Wrigley looks
at this and he's like,
these aren't women
playing baseball.
These are [bleep]ing
baseball players.
[bleep] yeah, dude!
It's so badass, right?
[ice jingling]
- This is my seventh inning
stretch.
- This is mine.
- All right, let's play ball.
- Yeah, okay.
So 1945 comes, right?
And World War 2 is ending.
Joe DiMaggio, Ted Williams,
the major, minor league
players come back
and they're like,
hi, everybody, yeah,
we've been at [bleep]ing war.
It's terrible.
We're ready to hit
some balls.
So they--they--and it ends up
fizzling out.
30 years passes,
and this story is forgotten
until 1985.
There was a reunion,
Helen Callan-delays.
- [laughs]
- This is harder now
than it was earlier.
- But you're still doing it.
- Kelly hand-delay,
Helen's oldest son, was like,
I'm gonna [bleep]ing
record this shit.
He whips his out
his camcorder,
and all these old ladies
are [bleep]ing playing ball
like they did
back in the [bleep]ing '40s.
Kelly Candaele creates
"A League of Their Own"
documentary.
it's a huge [bleep]ing deal.
[bleep]ing Penny Marshall sees
this documentary.
She's like,
what the [bleep]?
I didn't know this shit
existed in history.
Oh, maybe I should make
a movie about this story
because it's important
for women of all ages.
And if it wasn't for
"A League of Their Own,"
nobody would have ever known
that women can throw a ball
like the [bleep]ing men.
[inspirational music]